So they get the characteristic polynomial.
this Matrix
Okay, I just put the times just so you know that we are multiplying them
together. I'm just going to go and remove them again.
So we're going to take this product.
subtract it from a
a minus this Matrix
a minus that Matrix
the difference we will put inside the determinate function.
which will
output the characteristic polynomial which will
will look like you will see what it will look like now so we have
And this will be basically be well.
if you remember about the what we said about determinant, it will be the
the product
of the numbers on the main diagonal subtracted by the product
of the numbers across the other time, but
we must first take the difference of these two matrices. So
I'm going to take
Matrix a
and if we subtract from The Matrix a
This product Matrix this new Matrix Lambda. I
This will become 2 minus Lambda and
3 minus Lambda. So the determinant of
that.
this
expression
times
that expression minus this
component times that component and we
will get the following polynomial.
That is your characteristic polynomial.
step 3